august 25th marks five years since
nearly 740 000 mostly muslim rohingya
fled to bangladesh from myanmar
a flight triggered by a military
crackdown and widespread atrocities
un investigators and the u.s have called
it a genocide
bashley spoke to rohingya women youth
leaders and religious representatives in
the cox bazaar refugee camp
we told her that what we were not able
to do in myanmar we were able to do here
but we want to return to our home
she assured us that the un is working
hard and that soon we'll be able to
start the repatriation process
this is the first time a un high
commissioner for human rights has
visited bangladesh and the cox's bazaar
rohingya refugee camp since the post was
established 29 years ago
bangladesh's foreign minister arju
bashley to engage with myanmar and
ensure the repatriation of forcibly
displaced rohingya
the u.n high commissioner has shown much
concern about the rohingya and the u.n
has appreciated all our help they also
want bangladesh to continue to help the
rohingya and say they will stand beside
us on this
one refugee presented a letter to the
unhigh commissioner on behalf of all of
them
i wrote we escaped to bangladesh due to
atrocity committed against us women were
raped and burned to death there are
still some rohingya whose confiscated
land is not returned despite promises
made
if the myanmar government accepts all of
our rights and demands only then we will
return
bashley told refugees those forcibly
displaced would be repatriated under u.n
supervision and voluntarily and
diplomatic efforts were underway to make
that happen
but many here wonder how long that will
take and whether myanmar's government
will ever accept their demands can be
chaudhary al-jazeera daca